hello and welcome to the CEO playing
Maxime zette MS let's go oh I can do
yeah let's play the catalogue not
surprised how many people go for the
clothes cattleman it's some known from a
long time that black is under some
pressure there I mean often
it's still played quite frequently okay
so he went for a quick Bishop a 60 M
there are a couple of interesting
possibilities in Rock T one is one of
them I'm giving this part up I don't
quite remember don't quite remember the
theory diem
so let's see what's going to happen I
played a very early nights III that is
not so common usually you go Knight d2
but um you know let's see if he wants to
take on C form but even so ok does not
take one C form that is a bit of a
surprising decision so what is the point
here he wants to play some c5 I guess I
wonder I wonder if I should just take on
d5 I know I'm in a self pin but his
nights are so ridiculous you know before
he gets c5 in him
his nodes are just completely wrong I
mean maybe 97 to be 5 as an idea hmm
that is a problem maybe if he goes night
c7 I might I might need to play a form
which was not what I wanted to do yeah I
did not have this on the agenda
maybe b5 he needs he needs to get some
clay that is a very strange move night a
two-night a to was said yeah right into
its night b5 a move well I can't go
Queen d3 even
I mean here he has no square the bishop
has no square I'm intending to just take
played Bishop e3 and resigns almost okay
so where do we go
I only have this one
we should a3 is the only movement what
else what am I missing something that
okay I can't be at least exchange here
now with before but I wonder if this is
even the best probably not if I go
Bishop c1 yeah Bishop C oneness and then
he's got Bishop e2 that is the idea
anyway Scotty should be to him
okay then let's win the exchange I was
just looking if I have something even
better
Lucas trapped simply I will get the
exchange this way the position just
looked like there should be a knockout
yeah I was looking for something where
he immediately resigns but I didn't see
anything
that was significantly better
yeah he's some in a pin here if I'm not
is not so clear what the cleanest way is
to do this
let's go here 97 rook c6 is good for
white just limiting his pieces
preventing Knight b6 but there is no
completely clear way to win even more
material iam it's not not really on
where should I put this night the night
is not particularly well placed
threatening would be 5 now which would
help immensely oh it's true
I wanted to go Knight c4 but then he has
this and he has Knight takes d4 shoot
that is not good
otherwise Knight exif what we would just
was just winning I mean this way this
way it's not so simple
you
yeah no time unfortunately to make my
mind up a little bit had he lost some
time and I think the position is winning
because my rooks are so strong
I wrote b7 in fact but Jim yeah it was a
it was a bit odd I thought well we can
we can go here and here here here are
the most interesting points at the
beginning after Eve for the real thing
is he has to take on c4 it's the only
move that can question my setup at all
something like that is just very good
for white it's a very standard Clovis
Catalan position where blacks positions
us just sucks it's got space problems
and yeah why does it look better so that
is not really good and the only move
really is to take him and ask wide okay
what are you going to do I wasn't
totally certain what to do to be honest
and this is probably a theoretical
position but I wasn't entirely certain
95 sometimes an idea but yeah I thought
I thought the same that this is probably
not great in this particular situation I
have no good way to cover this as f-4s
not very desirable so my idea was Knight
d2 the point is that if he now grabs a
take with the apron and all of a sudden
activate the rook and then you get
something like this
now yeah maybe 94 or something I wanna
see anyone suggesting Age 4 yeah
something like that
this is some usually very okay
compensation for upon got a good center
like it doesn't have a very clear way to
improve the position for example Gaby
593 it's it's it's simply very difficult
to coordinate this but he has to do this
I mean I'm a bit surprised that the
engine gives me
Vantage Freud I thought it just is okay
let's say but that's what you have to do
with that this is just all so far too
passive
it's far too passive now this is an
interesting moment because C takes d5 is
maybe debatable the engine just wants to
play aged form and yeah it doesn't pay
any attention to the c5 possibility what
I was I wanted to just clarify the
situation and so that there is no
counter play with a pawn break yeah on
the queenside
now there is no palm break and if I can
just avoid any immediate material loss
on the C file I think I can then I'm
just going to be permanently better
because it's just a pretty awful French
yeah these are terribly bad there's no
pressure against this and they have
charges on them on the kingside he
played Knight c7 and oh yeah I can just
play a3 of course yeah
I didn't I didn't see that I mean it's
not difficult but and this would have
been very strong actually just sent us
back and now yeah that put put put the
pieces towards like this for example I
Section what the engine suggests just
this and then you start to play on the
on the kingside he's got no common plane
the C file I have good control of so
okay so this is this is not so
convincing and now quick Queenie 7s just
weird
just a weird move because you block here
you're only possible retreat square for
the Bishop Knight b8 engine suggestion
no yeah my idea is to do this anyway
just and unpin and then regroup towards
the kingside after this it's pretty
awful I think and now now Bishop a3 is
the only move quite obviously I know he
has to do this and then it's it's a
question I can
I can just stay put and let him take
while yeah exactly before that's an idea
that I also had because this is
basically the game and it takes this
Queen takes then I'm threatening b5
which would be yeah that would be a
strategic win yeah if I can manage to
box in this as well so he has to play
Bishop c4 and then I mean okay I'm
better but I mean it's got the square
yeah so it's still it's still a game
okay Bishop a5 and now I look for
something better than before it I mean
it this is perfectly enough but you know
just just win the material I had some
technical problems though I should just
take now of course that there is this is
simply I've got Bishop Bishop moves at
the end or that is simply I should just
take this is here like I have got this
it's very convincing or rook takes trade
and now this wins all the pawns him okay
that was a lot better and now I'm still
struggling a little bit technically I
have to prevent night at five you know
there that is fine now now is the
problem I I now miscalculated I am so I
saw that he's got ninety four here I
kind of suspected that but what would I
what I thought is this and I wanted to
take here and this fails to do it to
this it's very awkward now this is
pinned and there is this big threat and
black is now even better
I only saw before that this is winning
four right but funny enough he can even
take here and this is crazy black at
this particular moment is a full
down but I got such a weird weird
position that's so uncoordinated that
this actually works crazy he's he's
threatening this anyway a little bit at
least no he's threatening this sorry I
miscounted yeah yeah so Bishop takes
before that was based on a wrong
calculation I should simply stay put and
then try to convert the exchange yeah
the way it went
I was yeah I was winning again and yeah
activated the pieces and it's probably
at the very end there's not much left
really I've got I've got two plans I
have the idea to go here and stop
everything or in some cases just King
III 95s also an idea for an attack okay
guys thanks for watching